parce que vous en avez parlé très
librement romero elvis une petite
question sur l'épisode en 2021 cette
agression sexuelle vous avez évidemment
parler de ça très simplement vous allez
présenter vos excuses
comment ça s'est passé pour vous ce
moment et comment ça s'est passé
vous en avez parlé ensemble avec angèle
est les féministes elle est engagée
ouais ouais évidemment c'était
[Musique]
c'était une remise en question
nécessaire
c'était un geste déplacé je me suis
excusé
personnellement auprès de la personne je
veux dire et publiquement je pense que
c'était nécessaire de prendre ses
responsabilités de se rendre compte de
ce qu'on représente
publiquement et évidemment vous
connaissez ma soeur vous connaissez ses
convictions donc évidemment qu'on a
parlé et et on a discuté longuement et
sincèrement